sasha was not quarterback yeah he is
really not for sure you know when you
watch him being one of the most dynamic
athletes on the field regardless if this
right and then he it's like a slot
receiver with an arm and then they drop
back and be mechanically sound and
really hurts you from the pocket as well
he's got some special ability close
Kingsbury uh you know he know what type
of offense he runs obviously the hidden
cruising at high school have a great
relationship with him if we were going
to play under him I think it you know I
think it'd be a great deal from GM Steve
time to coach Kliff Kingsbury to
quarterback Tyler Murray the Cardinals
have one or two things going on here
Chris we boiled it down with the
assistance of the Cardinals website
right because they're the ones who have
teed this up for us all to figure out
Mike for some reason card viewed me
Cardinals website no they interviewed me
going you know what would you do a pic
number one and going through all the
scenarios which I was just shocked at
the aggression of the conversation so I
know it it is unbelievable sorry I
didn't mean to disrupt continue no
you're fine okay fine that's right
you're it's the first it's your first
day of your four days per week endeavor
and you're already cutting me off here
is if you're watching on NBCSN the the
headline from the Cardinals website this
is the website owned and operated by the
Cardinals Cardinals facing Kyler Murray
conundrum and if you read the article
you'll see that the analysis boils down
to this either the Cardinals really are
serious about taking Kyler Murray with
the first overall pick a year after they
trade it from 15 to tend to get
quarterback Josh Rosen or it's all a
ruse he's okay
the Cardinals website has cracked the
case and they're all over it and they
will be paying close attention to what
the Cardinals do as will the rest of us
and a part of the reason I don't write
Mike I mean are they are they that's
smart to bring the whole organization
together and the media department to
start this conversation and build the
fanfare for this do you think that's
possible
hey I think that's possible I think
that's entirely possible and here's the
question when does Josh Rosen become
part of the ruse I was talking about
this last hour I don't know
and I'm not saying Josh Rosen is
immature
but I think he would have to be mature
beyond his years to know that they're
just kind of messing with him the next
two months that they're just putting
this idea out there that maybe he'll be
traded by the team that maybe he's not
part of the long-term plans and yeah
that may undermine him within the eyes
of the media the fans his teammates that
he's trying to lead but he's gonna hold
that close to his vest I don't know that
he's in on it and if he is I don't know
that he can keep his mouth shut about it
cuz I think it would be very easy to let
someone know and then they let someone
know and the next thing you know it's
reported that it's all a ruse and
they're not trading Josh Rosen it's now
I don't know anything about that I
didn't say anything to anybody so if it
is a ruse I really want to know how far
it goes and it probably doesn't go far
beyond Michael Bidwell Steve calm and
Kliff Kingsbury but you know maybe it is
a ruse maybe it isn't and the drama
continues and the NFL loves it I think
the NFL would like that drama to
continue right up until the moment comes
to put someone's name on that first
draft card late April
yeah well it's a it's a great
conversation it's gonna be a really fun
to watch I mean from a lot of different
scenarios I mean the first thing you
brought up about Josh Rosen is he
involved in the ruse I would doubt that
I would doubt that they would let a
young player who's just getting done
with his rookie year who of course was a
little brash with his talking and things
like that in college anyways that's why
maybe he fell to the 10th pick because
people weren't sure what might come out
of his mouth so I would imagine they
didn't trust him with that type of
information but the real thing is I mean
are the Cardinals for real about taking
Kyler Murray one I guess the first thing
I would say about that conversation Mike
is you know and I got asked this by the
Arizona Cardinal website they've kind of
put me right right on the you know you
know put my feet to the fire going what
would you do ok here it is and I said I
think I would take Kyler Murray asking
me right now now taking Kyler Moorea 1
what is that I mean you brought it up
brought up so many great points last
week you don't want to be the team that
misses out on the next big thing right
the next Patrick mahomes the next
trendsetter in the NFL Arizona certainly
a team that could use a little pizazz
their franchise and around their
franchise in the Arizona you know in the
state of Arizona so I understand them
forwarding with the Cuyler Murray and
wanted to bring them there but then the
other thing is the trade market for Josh
Rosen and do they want to stick with
Josh Rosen so it's take Kyler Murray or
maybe get out of that first pic and
trade down and acquire morphix picks and
and fill more holes within your football
team is really what Steve time and is
getting paid the big bucks with Kliff
Kingsbury to figure it all out yeah and
I think the goal is you take full
advantage of the window that you have
and it's an extended window to evaluate
Kyler Murray to evaluate Josh Rosen go
back and study his performances from
last year that's a factor in all of this
you better carve out some time to go
back and look at Josh Rosen's tape from
every game he played last year and be
damn sure that this is a guy you're
ready to give up on if you are thinking
that Kyler Murray is the guy and as it
relates to a possible trade I know that
one unnamed GM told Peter King that
there probably will be a third-round
pick available for Josh Rosen I'm not
buying that and and look you never know
who the GM is you never know what the
motivation is you never know maybe
that's a GM that would like to get Josh
Lee this time of the year you're right
when when you consider that Rosen has
only 6.2 million left over the next
three years to be paid that is a steal
for a guy who was the 10th overall pick
right Scott McLuhan who was all over
Baker Mayfield last year he has been
telling the media that yes Kyler Murray
is the best quarterback prospect this
year by far but he's still worse than
the five who went last year and I'm not
here to agree or disagree with McLuhan
my point is there's value in Rosen
there's value in getting Rosen for 6.2
million over three years especially if
you're Washington where your hands are
tied Alex Smith contract right so what's
it worth to you to get a quarterback for
the next three years at 6.2 million I
would argue that because the Cardinals
have already paid this guy 11 million
that actually increases his trade yeah
Chris I totally feel you there I mean
that's the big thing that it doesn't
really like the old days right before we
had this this rookie salary cap you know
no team would ever think about drafting
a quarterback
number ten and then trying to trade them
away with the very next rap but because
of these rookie contracts and there's
not this huge financial commitment like
we saw with you know Sam Bradford's in
the world when they were picked number
one and had seventy five million dollar
contracts before they ever took a snap
and football it is different and it does
make the trade value easier that's gonna
be the big question question for Arizona
is there's just not a lot of teams that
are desperate in the quarterback
position right now you know you really
the top of the draft I don't think the
Giants of the jaguars are gonna be in
the market for a Josh Rosen I think
they're gonna look for the draft for the
future you know but the team's you
mentioned the Washington Redskins
certainly do the Dolphins want to move
you know move on from Ryan Tannehill did
they go with the Josh Rosen and like
that the bangles with bringing that you
know maybe they bring in somebody to
compete with Andy Dalton maybe it gets
to that point but at the very least I
don't agree with Scott McLuhan and what
he said right I mean you're saying the
five quarterbacks from last year are
better than Kyle Emery I don't agree
with that Kyler's Murray is a really
special entity and yes his size is the
one big concern but there's no other
concerns and I would like to remind
everybody out there last year the
Arizona Cardinals from everything I know
and I'm pretty sure I said it on the
show not long after the draft last year
they wanted Josh Allen more than they
wanted Josh Rosen I think Josh Rosen was
kind of the default guy so maybe the
organization never really bought in or
actually loved Josh Rosen I'm just
throwing that out there well and you got
a different coach who's on record saying
that he would take Murray with the first
pick in the draft and there's still
maybe a little of a Lou Holtz component
to that because he was getting his Texas
Tech team ready to play Oklahoma and
Kyle Emery at the time Kliff Kingsbury
said what he said but still there is
that belief there is that connection
there represented by the same agent for
crying out loud so there is smoke
whether the smoke has been put there
deliberately by the Cardinals to throw
off the scent that remains to be seen
and we'll see how that all plays out as
the the weeks unfold and you know if I'm
a team that's traded for Josh Rosen
Chris I want to go ahead and get that
done before my offseason program opens
but here's the thing the moment that
that trade happens we know that column
er is the
the Cardinals are gonna take and this
gets back to the whole presentation of
the ultimate show about nothing as far
as the NFL is concerned the draft
they're not gonna want the cat to be out
of the bag the NFL will be nudging the
Cardinals to keep Rosen on the roster
to keep all of this quiet until it's
time to unveil to everyone in Nashville
and watching around the world on 17
different networks right that this is
what's going down and people say oh they
won't oh no that isn't the way it works
oh yes that is the way it works when the
Rams traded up to get Jared Goff three
years ago they kept it close to the vest
until it was time to announce to the
world that it was Jared Goff even though
everybody knew it was Jared Goff and so
I think from the standpoint of if I'm
Washington and I want to get Josh Rosen
in April the 8th or whenever they're
their offseason program begins it begins
before the draft that's right I want
Rosen there before the draft and if that
happens the cats out of the bag and
there goes the drama yeah sure that
certainly does but I think that Arizona
probably would not want to do that
because I would think the way that they
could get the most value in a trade for
a Josh Rosen would be to go up all the
way to the draft and you know you're
gonna have teams that are gonna get done
with free agency here and not
necessarily that this is where the
timeline will get interesting in this
trade usually teams you know of course
you're gonna have free agency the
Washington Redskins they have Colt McCoy
let you know let's let's other teams out
there they don't sign the quarterback
that they fancy or feel like they can
lead them into the 2019 season they're
gonna know before the draft because a
lot of teams usually have an OTA three
or four practices before the draft to
see where their teams at is there
anything glaring let's get one more look
at our team to see oh gosh we have to
draft or do this to get things done and
I think that's where really the price
for Josh Rosen could get sky-high as
teams get closer to the draft and they
go maybe it is a Washington Redskins
where they just go okay we thought Colt
McCoy might be the guy but he's not now
okay we're not sure if we really want
him to be the leader of the 2019 season
maybe that's when they called the
Arizona Cardinals and offer up more than
maybe they would have at this point of
the season or an off season because they
finally realize
okay we definitely have a deficiency at
the quarterback position and you know
this is the other reality as well when
you've already paid Josh Rosen eleven
million dollars you can keep him right
you can make Murray one and Rosen - you
don't have to trade Josh Rosedale that's
another alternative for the Arizona
Cardinals and you know quarterbacks such
an important position in football the
most important position on the field
what's wrong with having two guys in the
event caller Murray does get injured
that's one of the big question marks
when it relates to caller Murray's long
term NFL future why not keep Josh Rosen
around if you can convince him to stick
around as the back
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports